so from Monday some lockdown
restrictions will be easing in England
we just heard about some the measures
that will change in Scotland do you
think it's too soon to be easing the
lockdown there's an awful lot of people
Sophie who are absolutely desperate to
get back to work there are children who
need to go back to school and labour
supports the lockdown easing but it's
critically important that as that
happens it's done in the safest way that
it possibly can be and I think that's
where over the weekend we've seen some
scientists in particular raising
concerns about whether the way the
government is going about this is safe
or not and we need to make sure maximum
safety is always applied so the public
the public can be reassured about what
they're being asked to do is is safe for
them and we'll just try and pin you down
on some of the specifics because of
course heaven wants to make sure that
things are as safe as possible I don't
think anyone would disagree with that
and schools are a right at the top of
the agenda at a minute with more primary
schools in England opening to more
pupils from tomorrow now in last week's
programs Sir Michael Wilshaw the former
head of Ofsted said that keeping kids
away from school risks a lost generation
and undoing some of that progress that's
been made for disadvantaged children in
recent years so does labour support more
primary schools going back from Monday
or not labour supports a gradual
reopening of the schools in a way that
is safe for children for teachers for
everyone else that works in the schools
and it's critical before now parents are
not going to send their kids back to
school if they don't think it's
absolutely safe to do so so there's a
there's an issue here about reassurance
and providing parents with that
information but but where it's possible
to open schools and absolutely we won't
see schools open where you know am i
aware that in some communities up to a
third of children are not getting any
any education at all because they don't
have the technology at home that allows
them to have lessons now two months
three months four months and potentially
for a child to be out of school is an
incredibly big gap in their education so
all of us want to see schools oh but it
has to be done in a gradual way that
maintains parents confidence that it's
safe for their child to go
are you're the shadow community
secretary so you're responsible for
local government I mean is it acceptable
that there's a bit of a piecemeal
approach here with some local
authorities recommending that schools
open some not we're effectively living
in a postcode lottery when it comes to
our children's education actually local
authorities will take decisions that are
appropriate for their areas based on the
science and the data as it applies to
their locality we don't have a single
rate of infection of this disease across
the whole country it's much higher in
some areas than it is in other areas so
the way to deal with that is to set
clear national standards that everybody
can understand in particular localities
well just be clear what what are those
clear national standards then because I
think it's important to be specific and
you saying that if if infections are
above a certain area in one local
government area then it's acceptable for
schools to open what are those national
standards where the rate of infection is
higher as it is in some areas in the
northwest for instance we've seen some
councils I think in the northwest both
labor and conservative talking about not
wanting schools to reopen quite as
quickly because the rate of infection is
higher now the national standards say to
only be done in a way that is safe to
limit the spread of infection now I
think it's quite right to have a set of
national standards like that but local
application based on the different
circumstances in each locality so that
the cutoff be that if you try to apply
one-size-fits-all to this when the
circumstances are so very different in
different parts of the country
you'll put children and their families
at risk and nobody wants to see that the
schools need to open as fast as possible
but it has to be done in a way that's
safe so what should the cutoff be then
for an acceptable level of infection for
schools to reopen well that's going to
be a decision that will be taken locally
it's not going to be dictated by me
schools are opening from tomorrow it's
the kind of thing you should have worked
out by now isn't it well it's the kind
of thing that local authority leaders
have already been working out by talking
to teaching unions
head teachers and parents region by
region the way they found this in Wales
actually is is worth looking at because
the Welsh Labour government brought
together the education unions parent
parents groups health experts and they
built a canoe
census around that now I'd like to see
that happening in England unfortunately
so far the government hasn't chosen to
go down that route but I think the key
to reassurance are getting this right is
to build consensus as much as possible
so people saying that and if you're
saying that what's happening in Wales is
the right thing to do where they're not
reopening schools are you saying that
schools shouldn't be reopening from
tomorrow no I'm saying the decisions
need to be taken based on the
circumstances in different areas we want
schools to open as soon as possible
because that's the best thing for
children but we don't want schools to
open in areas where it isn't information
sitting here in London those are
decisions that need to be taken locally
based on local circumstances and I
believe that's the right thing to do
okay now a big part of the government's
route out of lockdown is the tests and
trace system it's only just started
there has been concerned from some union
leaders some teaching union leaders at a
school shouldn't be reopening until
that's had time to really bed in what do
you want to see well with contact
tracing there I mean it's critical if
we're going to take these the lockdown
that the tests trace and isolate program
works very effectively and efficiently
people can't start going back out into
the world if they're not certain that
people who get infected and be
identified and asked to lock down now
the government has in my opinion wasted
time on getting this program right just
it was Friday last week so with four
working days to go until Boris Johnson's
deadline for having a what he called a
world-beating contact tracing system up
and running by tomorrow when local
authority leaders were told they were
going to have to take a lead in this the
government had two months before that
when they could have been talking to
local authority leaders and council
leaders were telling them two months ago
that they wanted I mean the government
was too slow in involving them
nevertheless local authority leaders and
that's where the contact tracing
expertise is based have step they've
been working with them a program well we
saw over this week then some scientists
raising concerns just let local the
authority leaders have done that
everything is not yet in place for that
that system to be absolutely robust so
we are calling on the government at Pace
to fix some of the remaining problems we
believe they can do this quickly we need
to see better data sherry so that local
authorities know exactly who needs to be
contacted and asked to isolate local
authorities are saying they need more
powers to enforce local lockdowns if
there's an outbreak for instance in an
office block or a particular street and
where there are people who all recent of
their own personal income are less
likely to self isolate if there are if
they're asked to because they're
self-employed or they're on very low
rates of statutory sick pay there needs
to be financial support to help them to
self isolate these are all things that
government can fixed very very quickly
if they choose to and it's essential
that is done if you're going to have
public confidence and an effective and
robust contact tracing system